- [Interviewer] All right, Kristen.
- [Kristen] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Kristen,
where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Originally, I'm from South Carolina.
- [Interviewer] South Carolina, what city?
- Myrtle Beach.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I know Myrtle Beach.
And how long have you been out here?
- I've been here for six years now.
- [Interviewer] What
brought you out to LA?
- I actually came out here to
try to get clean off heroin
but that didn't go so well.
- [Interviewer] There's
heroin in South Carolina too?
- Yeah, a lot.
- [Interviewer] I though
it was just out here.
- I know, right?
No, it's pretty bad there too.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how did your get
introduced to new heroin?
- My boyfriend sold
heroin that I was with--
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
Yeah, I went from doing
pills to doing the heroin.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that
a common transition, right?
- Yeah, and then when I came out here
it was so much cheaper that
I really got bad into it.
That's how I ended up in the wheelchair.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
What happened?
Somebody put battery acid in
my dope and gave me a hot shot.
- [Interviewer] Oh no.
- Yeah, so it burnt me
from the inside out.
I lost 60% of the muscle in my left leg,
40% in my right leg
and 10% in each arm
from where the acid at
birth through my skin.
- [Interviewer] I see the scars.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How long
ago did that happen?
- A year ago.
- [Interviewer] A year ago.
- Yeah, I just learned how to walk again.
- [Interviewer] So, do
you think there's hope
for you walking down the road?
- I hope so.
I'm confident, the doctor
said if I keep practicing,
cause muscle has memory.
If you keep practicing with
it, then there's a good chance
I'll be able to do it again.
- [Interviewer] Oh, good.
So, where do you stay now,
are you on the street?
- I'm homeless.
- [Interviewer] Do you stay in a tent
or something like that?
- Yeah, I have a tent.
- [Interviewer] And then
what do you do for money?
- Whatever I can, you know,
girls do all kinds of
things for money these days.
- [Interviewer] Yes, no kidding.
- Not always the best
things, but you know.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, this
neighborhood, you see it all.
- Yeah, definitely, it's
kind of dangerous out here,
but you still got to take care of yourself
and eat every day.
You know, it's hard.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, for
guys in your situation
it becomes really hard, right?
- Oh, yeah, for sure.
- [Interviewer] At least
women there's an easy way out.
- Right, yeah, no, the men have way harder
cause they don't just have a pussy.
They can't just go make some
quick money like that but--
- [Interviewer] Now, does
being in a wheelchair
does that help or hurt?
- It's hurts so bad.
I can't make money like I used to at all.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
nobody wants to pick up a--
- Yeah, nobody wants to pick up a girl
in a wheelchair, you know?
Yeah, so it's tough.
- [Interviewer] And do you
have children of your own?
- I do, I have a daughter, she's 19.
- [Interviewer] Where is she?
- South Carolina.
- [Interviewer] Who raised her?
- My father did.
- [Interviewer] Your father did.
So, you were kind of on
the street for a long time?
- Yeah, I got divorced when
I was 23 from my husband
and after that my life just fell apart
and I started doing drugs
and had been doing them ever since.
- [Interviewer] Did you
have a job before that?
Or you were just raising your kid?
- [Kristen] Just raising my daughter.
My dad owned a bar and I worked for him.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and
what do you see down the road
for you for the next five years?
Do you'd like to take your legs back?
- [Kristen] Yeah, I'd
love to learn to, you know
get stronger and I'm going
to the methadone clinic now.
So, hopefully I can keep myself
going in the right direction
with that and maybe one day get a job.
That would be nice
and I'm working on getting housing.
So, my main goal was to
just get off the streets.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
the wheelchair makes it
doubly hard, right?
- [Kristen] Yes, for sure.
It really does.
- [Interviewer] Do people
take advantage of you
because they see you as more
vulnerable being in a chair?
- [Kristen] I think sometimes they do.
Plus I'm really friendly and
I like to talk to people.
So, they take advantage of
people that they see are nice,
they see that as weak.
- [Interviewer] Right,
they prey on the weak here.
- [Kristen] Yeah, for sure.
And like a lot of the tricks
they'll try to like have sex
with you and then not pay you
and kick you out the car and then fuck
I'm seven or eight blocks
from home and I can't walk.
What do I do then?
You know, I got to have
somebody pick me up
literally and carrying me back.
- [Interviewer] That's happened?
- [Kristen] Yeah, that's happened.
So, not good.
Yeah, not everybody is a good
person out here, you know?
- [Interviewer] You start
wondering if there are any.
- Yeah, a lot of the times,
they're far and few
between that's for sure.
It seems like everybody out
here has an ulterior motive.
You can't really call anybody your friend
cause you don't the ones
you let close to you
are usually the ones
that are the first people
to hurt you or rob you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, even
it seems like the nicest
kindest person will do whatever the fuck
it takes once they're addicted to the drug
that they absolutely need.
- Oh, for sure, there's
no limits when it comes
to them needing their fixed.
You know, I know that myself.
- [Interviewer] They'll do anything.
- Anything.
- [Interviewer] Sell their kids.
- They'll do whatever.
- Literally, literally.
- [Interviewer] You've seen that, right?
- Yeah, it's terrible.
- [Interviewer] So, tell
me about your childhood?
You grew up with--
- I grew up with great parents.
My parents were wonderful.
My father was in the
military for 27 years.
My mother was a housewife.
I grew up on and off of air
force bases, good schools.
My mom got sick with cancer when I was 13
and she died when I was 15.
So, that was pretty hard.
Then it was just me and my dad
and he got this new girlfriend
and we didn't get along
and everything just kind of spiraled
out of control after that.
Now, me and my dad don't talk anymore.
But, he did raise my daughter
and I do still talk to her,
thank God.
But, I've tried to talk
to him since my accident
and being in the hospital,
but he still won't talk to me.
So, I guess he's still mad
for some of the stuff I did.
- [Interviewer] Well, Kristen
thank you for talking to me.
- Yeah, no problem.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything.
- Yes, thank you.
- [Interviewer] All right.
- What are you using this for?
- [Interviewer] I put these up on YouTube.
- Nice, very cool.
- [Interviewer] So, just
like information for people,
like for young kids that
might be considering getting
into a gang or doing drugs or whatever.
- Right, oh good.
- [Interviewer] It's just a good
bit of information for them
to look at like, oh wow.
- Right, so they can stop
before they get, awesome.
- [Interviewer] Especially
with the gangs it's like,
you do that death or prison.
- That's it.
- [Interviewer] Guaranteed.
- And that's it, guaranteed.
- [Interviewer] There's no
chance of that not happening.
- I see people get shot
and killed and beat up
here every day.
So, and I would hate to see a teenage girl
go through anything
like I've went through.
So, if this helps anybody
in any way, that's great.
That's great.
You're doing a good thing.
That's a positive message to try to deter
our younger generation
from growing up into this.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
sometimes you don't realize
how serious this actually can get.
- And it can get so serious,
it's life and death that here every day.
So, if you can stop them before that
I think that's a great thing.
- [Interviewer] Thanks so much Kristen.
- Yeah, no problem.